foreign
let's go out to Sarah in Florida what up
Sarah how we doing
oh just just partying here how are you
doing me too if by parting you mean I'm
drinking water and I'm at work but
what's up
yeah hiding from my dogs
um
so
um I have a question for you are you
adult are you a dog mom say no say no ah
uh not a I used to think
they're a pet owner I'm a pet owner I
love it okay all right so you're a
former dog parent who's transitioned to
pet owner what's up because yep because
my husband and I are expecting our first
baby in May so Mike you're gonna be a
human parent wow a human parent yes
real quick to the YouTubers okay relax
you don't know I love my I know you love
your pet you're not a pet parent there's
no such thing you're a pet owner and
that's great I love my dog often more
than any of my other family members but
I'm not a parent of a dog I'm a parent
of two kids all right transition back to
Sarah what up okay she's having a kid
congratulations when is your baby coming
yeah see May May 19th is her due date oh
it's a her
it's a beautiful baby girl I know she's
beautiful already I don't even
[Laughter]
need narcissistic personality disorder
so um I think that you should possibly
consider John uh as a as a name that's a
beautiful daughter's name John uh John
John anyway okay so tell me how can I
help how can I help
um so I guess my my question is um how
do I and my husband prepare for the
transition to being parents and how do I
personally handle um the fear of losing
my marital relationship as it is now as
well as handle the fear of losing myself
as we transition into parental roles
ah such a great question all right to
answer your first question how do you
prepare for being a parent I want you to
get a 30 pack of of like Miller tall
boys and I want you to go stand in
traffic and that's the best that's the
best way you can prepare for what's
coming okay and hopefully I'm just
kidding don't do any of those things I
just said all right so
oh man how honest can I be with you
um there is zero percent chance you hang
on to your marriage as it is right now
and that's a good thing and there's zero
percent chance you hang on to your life
and your autonomy
as you know it now and that's a great
thing your husband's Gonna Change you're
gonna change your house is gonna change
everything about you what you know about
yourself is Gonna Change
all of that is going to be changed it's
going to change that's gonna be good you
will lose yourself
okay and I think this is just my
personal opinion I don't have any signs
to back this up let's just be sitting
with countless people
I believe that if you take away like
hormonal dysregulation and all that
chaos that happens physiologically
I think one of the core mental health
challenges with new parents
is them trying to
um take their old life and somehow drag
it into the future
with their new kid
and what happens is you end up every
second of every day you're comparing he
used to be do this and now he's like
this she used to look like this and now
it's like this we used to have this much
time and my wife used to just want to
make out all the time and now she falls
asleep at 7 15. like all those things
happen and in and of themselves they're
fantastic
it's when you start comparing them to
the old stuff all of the time and you
create this narrative that somehow we're
broken somehow we're not working right
somehow we've just got to get back on
track not realizing you're in a totally
different train going a totally
different direction now does that make
sense
yeah yeah it does here's the best way I
can describe it this may be a terrible
analogy
um have you ever been to like a water
park
oh yeah okay all right so I love water
oh yeah you're in Florida I love water
parks yeah I love I hate heights but I
love the water ride like the highest one
and you just hey you just you shoot off
and you fly right and you're just kind
of bumping it barely as you go down
imagine flying off that and then
grabbing on and hang it on
you're going to pull your shoulders out
of socket that water is on a jet stream
and it's going to blast you in the face
it's gonna sandpaper your skin off it's
going to make it where you can't breathe
or you can jump off that thing and just
let go
most people jump off that thing
especially with their first kid and they
try to hang on to everything that used
to be and what they do is they end up
getting themselves hurt okay so okay as
you enter the season
if nobody's told you this and they
probably have in their own weird God
have you gotten so much crap ridiculous
advice from everybody
oh God yeah isn't it insane in the wild
it's it's madness has your husband
lectured you yet please say yes
no he's actually been great okay good
hey you are you're you're welcome
you're a one percenter dude I had people
giving me advice in in the grocery store
a lot like I don't know you why are you
talking about my wife's body weird like
it was madness madness everybody's had
advice and wisdom and blah blah all
right here's the deal if someone tells
me to enjoy the sleep while I can one
more time I might lose it
up in here up in here listen okay
your body will not be your own
okay okay make peace with that
it sucks I've watched I watched my wife
a few times I was like I don't I I don't
know what's happening to your soul
um but feeding lack of sleep feeling
like a zombie insecurity body changes
hormone regulation like hormones playing
pickleball with your emotions just going
bananas right all them you're about to
walk into an industry an entire
ecosystem designed for one thing to make
moms feel guilty so they'll buy crap
you are entering into that world what
kind of soap are you using does it have
parabens in it oh my gosh did you know
that and listen the fact that I just
said that I can't tell you how many DMS
I'm gonna get like well here's the thing
about parabens there's and yeah anyway
you're gonna you're not gonna be able to
rest it's gonna be chaos and listen
that's okay
it's think about going off the water
park and there's a way to to turn your
mindset if you practice it which is I'm
so tired I can't even I don't know what
day it is I don't know what time it is
what a blessing I've got a healthy kid
and I get to be in this season you see
what I'm saying there's it's going to be
you practicing that mindset shift okay
now
um here's what I think the most
important planning you can do moving
forward
is not about trying to predict
everything that's coming because it's
just so different
um I I think I've told the story on this
show my friend
um fat shot my friend John there was I
had three friends and um uh there was
two of us were named John so I was hyper
John he was fat John he's one of my best
friends on planet but John would he had
kids first and whenever his and his
wife's name is Jen she's like one of the
greatest women on planet Earth and
whenever he first had his kid his first
daughter
he quit hanging out with us and we hung
out regularly every Monday night and I
started thinking this is on me I was
like man Jen is killing this guy
like suddenly there's one kid and she
won't let him hang out with the guys
anymore or whatever and then he had
another kid and he disappeared and I was
like man
what they need to fix their marriage
dude and then I had Hank
and I'll never forget McGee John and I
were out having Gypsy queso and I was
like uh
dude why didn't you tell me and he just
smiled real big and he said something
like say it and I was like I I always
thought you didn't want to hang out with
us because you weren't allowed because
Jen wasn't allowing you to
you didn't want to hang out with us
because you wanted to sit on your couch
and hold your baby and you'd rather
spend time with that one-year-old than
with us and he was like yep and I said
why didn't you ever tell me and he goes
because I couldn't have explained it you
just have to experience it and so
everybody with their advice and their
wisdom and their yeah all that crap let
that go into What In One Ear smile let
it go out the other because they're
trying to love you the best they can
I think the most important thing you and
your husband can do is set up a
structure
that you commit to before you have a
baby
where you have a road back to one
another on a regular basis what does
that look like in real life every Monday
night we sit down together and say how
are you
every Monday night we say we sit down we
ask the same question how can I love you
this week how can I love you for the
next three days because that's how fast
things are changing
and you are gonna have to practice
saying your needs out loud
does that make sense is that fair
yeah it does it makes sense
once a I mean four times a week we're
gonna have skin on skin contact that may
end up in us making out it may be I just
need
to feel somebody else's heartbeat other
than that kid
I need somebody not using my body as a
jungle gym I just need to rest in you
can we just hold hands let me put my my
hand on your chest can I just breathe
for for 30 minutes but we're gonna do
skin on skin contact four times a week
right
um I promise that we won't be led by our
feelings but we're going to talk about
them you see what I'm saying like we're
going to build a structure so that as
we're building this new life we keep
coming back to one another and we don't
end up in these other planets
does that make sense that is yeah okay
you talk I've been talking a lot
I'm like that already um we you know we
check in it's kind of
I mean more of every day I kind of try
to start the day with you know we both
like what can I do for you today how can
how can I help you today what can you
know just you know something to help the
other person or acknowledge that you
know whatever you like that our needs
changed on a day on a what could be a
daily basis I'm just afraid
of um
I think just in the as as I'm getting
further into her arrival and losing
a lot more of my own like this isn't my
body anymore like I don't I don't feel
like myself I'm I feel like I'm having a
hard time I'm starting to have that hard
time of like
physically connecting because I don't
feel like I'm at my best so I'm trying
to prep and I I guess there's no way to
really prepare for the fact that it's
like yeah it's not going to be like when
we got married like it's gonna feel the
same
what I Can't Describe to you on this
side of it
is the feelings are
10x
like I it's hard to say like I promise
you and it sounds crazy but sex will be
better in your 40s than it is in your
20s that sounds insane right I promise
it is
um I promise in the same way you and
um
your husband were like sneaking makeouts
between like not getting caught with
your parents or whatever
I hear this from couples all the time
I'm looking at a couple right now like
you're going to be sneaking make out so
your kids don't catch you and the same
level like right so the same heart
racing and like how are we gonna like
your life will just be different it's
not going to be less than in fact it's
going to be infinitely better than it's
just hard to capture that in words right
now and it will be found in stolen
glances and it will be found in Gentle
Touch as you're both reaching for the
same thing in the fridge and it will be
it'll be passing moments of just looking
at each other like in those with like
you look at him and be like oh you got a
whole night of sleep last night I hope
you're happy with yourself and he'll
look at you and say oh you get this you
get to just stay in bed and hold the
baby all day I right and you're gonna
have those moments here's here's the
magic phrase in my house
the story I'm telling myself is and
that's how we preface the conversation
and so I think it would be really really
lovely for your marriage and for you and
for your husband to say the story I'm
telling myself is is that you're you're
not going to think I'm pretty anymore
because I've gained 35 pounds say those
words out loud
the story I'm telling myself is I'm
gonna have a baby you're never going to
want to like make out with me again and
we're gonna turn into one of those
couples that just never has sex and
watches Netflix all the time
story I'm telling myself is is that I'm
losing control of my body and I don't
know what's happening like say those
things out loud
in a way that's not attacking him
because if you let it all bottle up it
explodes like shaking a two liter right
say it in a way that he can hear it and
um and that's what I say have a
structure don't start don't be like yeah
usually we start every morning
make it put it on the calendar no matter
what come hell or high water Sunday
nights we sit down and talk we go
through our calendar we check in with
one another
the story I'm telling myself is that I
was not a very good dad last week how
can I do how can I step it up
and the story I'm telling myself is you
keep saying stupid things and the story
I'm telling myself is you're actually
stupid right instead of I'm just a
clueless dad and I don't know I'm trying
my best I'm reading all the books I ask
my friends listen Sarah I went to all of
the the baby classes with my wife I went
to all those things I went to as many of
her doctor appointments as I could I
wanted to be the Super hip Ultra Modern
dad like I'm all in
nobody told me that my kids would crap a
hundred thousand times in a single day I
had no idea I thought they'd go twice
like a normal person they don't and so
he's gonna say God Almighty how many
diapers are we buying and you're gonna
think
well if you were just around and plugged
into your daughter and you weren't so
busy right and that's how that and then
all of a sudden boom you create two
separate lives right there
and so being able to go
yeah he didn't know and he actually is
trying really hard he just didn't know
and in fact you could say I thought they
would do it like five times I didn't
know it was 19.
um y'all can sit down and say the story
I'm telling myself is you're not plugged
into our daughter and he can say I'm
reading I'm I'm listening I'm talking to
people I just can't keep up I don't know
it's all happening so fast and that
vulnerability is going to be where y'all
stay connected and build something
completely new
does that make sense okay
that makes a lot of sense actually that
makes me feel a lot better so it's a
it's a weird thing
um one of my great mentors Randy Harris
gave me this analogy one time
it's like you are swinging through the
jungle on a vine
and you are just realizing that your
Vine is about to run out of Swing
and so you let go and the other Vine you
don't see it coming through all the
leaves and trees
and you look up though and you can see
on that tree there's a whole bunch of
other people up there and they made it
so you know the vines come and you just
gotta let go and believe that it's on
its way that's where you're entering
into
and the more you try to over predict and
over
guesstimate and over dream about what
this is going to look and feel like the
more disorienting it's going to be when
reality hits and it's very very
different and it doesn't feel like that
at all
so go off the ride let go head down that
slide and enjoy that ride
and oh my gosh that was I'm basically a
rapper I I was incredible
um I'm also putting out a hip-hop record
after this if you guys want to pick it
up
um
I I want you to enjoy the ride and make
sure you're staying plugged in to your
husband the whole way
with your fears with your concerns with
your ability to say your needs out loud
and just look at the countless folks
like us on the other side smile and
saying dude it's so incredible it's so
incredible we can't wait to see it on
this side of it uh let us know how your
baby goes send us a picture and we'll
make sure we announce especially if you
name it Jonna I think that's a great
daughter's name